nous venons de vivre un moment
absolument historique pour la france et
pour l'ensemble des collectivités qui la
composent pendant longtemps on a négligé
le rôle des communes et de l'ensemble
des autres collectivités
peut-être parce que le gouvernement
flottant sur son nuage pensait qu'il
dirigeait le pays tout seul
cette crise a montré une chose sans la
pluie des communes il n'y aurait pas eu
lutte possible contre la propagation de
virus sans l'appui les communes il n'y
aurait pas eu de soutien ont pu faire
sans l'appui des communes les masses que
l'état a hélas dilapidés dans des
périodes plus fastes qu'aujourd'hui
n'aurait pas pu être acheminée auprès
des populations voire même auprès des
soignants
quand nous sommes substitue à l'état
pour leur apporter le nécessaire cette
crise nous devons en tirer des
enseignements
ce sont des enseignements de terrain
nous avons nous les mères et nos élus
gérer l'urgence au quotidien en
réinventant des procédures forcément
inédite pour assurer le bien-être et la
santé de nos concitoyens nous l'avons
fait avec une première exigence qui
était la continuité du service public
parce que la france c'est aussi un
service public qui soutient une
population surtout lorsqu'elle est
désemparé surtout lorsqu'elle est
confrontée à des difficultés
nous l'avons fait en réorganisant nos
services nous l'avons fait pour que
l'essentiel perdure pour que celles et
ceux qui sont le plus secoué par la
crise soit par la maladie soit par ses
conséquences économiques et sociales
puissent trouver en nous un recours et
qui puisse à un moment précis de leur
existence dramatique bien souvent leur
tendre la main et leur dire que la
nation toute entière à travers la
commune
travers le maire était là pour les cd
nous l'avons fait lorsqu'il s'est agi je
le disais d'équiper nos soignants qui
ont étaient désemparés et c'est une
leçon que nous ne devons jamais oublier
il n'est pas possible que dans un pays
développé comme notre france nous
puissions être réduit à avoir des
actions d'urgence pour donner le
nécessaire à celui qui sont là pour
soigner notre population
depuis longtemps nous disons que il faut
réformer l'hôpital
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus une urgence
est une nécessité absolue et les maires
en nous vraiment sur le terrain la
conscience aiguë il faudra d'ailleurs
que les maires retrouvent toute leur
place au sein de l'organisation de
l'hôpital public
on les a éloignés en leur faisant
présidé un conseil de surveillance là où
avant il présidait le conseil
d'administration et le retour en force
des collectivités
c'est un gage de plus que l'hôpital sera
considéré dans sa mission première de
service public
mais cette action vous l'avons menée
aussi en lien avec l'état il n'y a pas
eu de conflit les lieux un dialogue
sérieux et même sévère parfois lorsque
l'état nous poussaient un peu trop à
faire des bêtises
je pense en particulier à la rentrée
scolaire il était nécessaire que nous
puissions organiser mais à la condition
c'est ce que nous avons souhaité faire à
chalon sur saône de prendre le temps
d'assurer la santé de l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative les enfants et
leurs familles les enseignants les
agents de la ville travaillent dans les
écoles le service public de l'éducation
nationale est un service partagé
il a beau reposer sur une organisation
institutionnelle de l'état sans les
communes sans les départements sans les
régions pour les lycées il n'y a pas de
système éducatif qui va nous avons donc
joué notre rôle et nous l'avons fait
avec cette conscience aiguë que la crise
nous a replacé en première ligne que la
crise a redonné à l'institution
communale la place essentielle de
piliers de base en même temps de notre
organisation sociale
s'il n'y avait pas eu les communes aux
citoyens auraient été livrés
le confinement n'auraient pas été
respectées et nous aurions forcément
étaient dans des considérations
dramatiques en termes de propagation
d'épidémies nous avons joué ce rôle
et aujourd'hui nous demandons à l'état
et singulièrement au gouvernement qui a
trop tendance à l'oublier dans les
sphères
ces restes dans lesquels ils se croient
évolué bien trouve souvent que les
communes soient reconnus comme les
collectivités essentielles de la
république française
[Musique]